Now, finally let's talk
about the occasional and
the cultural segmentation options.
The occasional segmentation focuses on
certain occasions that are completely
independent of the customer.
Now, you don't care about demographics.
You just care about occasions
such as going out for
ice cream, taking a vacation, or
as Coke famously did it, being thirsty.
Coke's campaign doesn't care if you're
a man, woman, living in Uruguay or
Ukraine or if you have high
socio-economic status or low.
All they care about is are you thirsty,
it's very simple.
And finally there's
cultural segmentation.
With this you'll classify the markets
according to cultural origin.
Now this can be incredibly powerful
given that understanding a culture can
give you so much insight to certain
groups of customers and their behaviors.
Now when you use cultural segmentation,
you'll be able to
communicate well with a given
culture in the most effective way.
Cultures can be large,
they can be nationwide.
Or they can be small and
reflect a particular region such as the
Bay Area or even the startup culture.
And so now we've talked about a few
different types of segmentation.
Behavioral psychographic, demographic,
geographic, occasional and
cultural segmentation.
Let's explore how to
best segment your market.